[Musik]
mehr klarheit im kampf gegen korona
bundespräsident steinmeier redet der
politik ins gewissen
auf ein neues nach längeren gesprächen
in baden württemberg wollen grüne und
cdu ihre koalition fortsetzen und mit
kommt ins neue heim kairo zelebriert den
umzug von 22 mumien altägyptischer
pharaonen und pharaonen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
an meiner seite ist mal wieder rudi
cerne für den spruch hallo show guten
abend deutschland sei kein pandemie
weltmeister aber auch kein total
versager das sagt der bundespräsident
ungewöhnlich deutlich kritisiert er in
einer fernsehansprache die regierenden
zugleich appelliert er aber auch an alle
lasst uns nicht so viel zweifeln und
schwarz malen sondern aufs können
konzentrieren
patricia wieder meyer das land sei in
einer vertrauenskrise es brauche nun
klare und pragmatische regeln im kampf
gegen korona das ist die botschaft die
heute aus schloss bellevue kam der
bundespräsident fordert einen
gemeinsamen kraftakt gegen die dritte
welle kaufen wir uns alle zusammen lebe
landsleute holen wir raus was in uns
steckt empören wir uns nicht nur über
die anderen oder über die da oben zeigen
wir doch nicht ständig was nicht geht
sondern dass es geht wenn alle ihren
teil tun
ja es habe fehler gegeben beim testen
beim impfen und bei der digitalisierung
jetzt aber dürfe es keinen politischen
streit als selbstzweck mehr geben klare
worte an bund länder und parteien
wir brauchen klarheit und
entschiedenheit wir brauchen
verständliche und pragmatische
regelungen damit die menschen
orientierung haben damit dieses land
wieder das aus sich herausholen kann was
in ihm steckt für steinmeier ist impfen
der weg aus der pandemie er selber bekam
diese woche eine spritze mit astrazeneca
das impfen ist der wichtigste schritt
auf unserem weg heraus aus der pandemie
also nutzen sie die möglichkeiten machen
sie mit ostern könne ein fest der
hoffnung werden wenn man vertrauen habe
und mehr aufeinander acht geben so der
bundespräsident in seiner ansprache und
die ganzen sechs minuten des
bundespräsidenten sehen sie direkt nach
uns wir brauchen klarheit fordert frank
walter steinmeier
doch derzeit überwiegt eher die
unübersichtlichkeit denn es gelten sehr
unterschiedlich
gruner regeln auch über ostern beispiel
private kontakte da dürfen sich in
nordrhein-westfalen und weiteren ländern
zwei haushalte mit insgesamt fünf
personen treffen sogar bei einer
inzidenz über 100 zugleich gelten in
berlin und brandenburg nachts ausgangs
beschränkungen auch in hamburg wie die
menschen damit umgehen zeigt alexander
hettich
erst vor wenigen tagen gab es hier einen
polizeieinsatz gegen hunderte
partytouristen heute bleibt es ruhig
die düsseldorfer zieht an den rhein in
die sonne zu hause bleiben ist für viele
keine option mehr
es bleiben halt so die ideen langsam aus
man hat alles aufgeräumt alles
weggeputzt amazon netflix wenn man das
so sagen darf durchgespielt da bleibt
halt nachher nicht mehr viel was man
noch machen kann
gastronom hassan khalil bewirtet
normalerweise in jeder stunde 500 gäste
an solchen tagen heute ein paar schmalem
würstchen to go kein echter trost auch
dazu dass ging in der politik für ihn
viel zu oft hin und her
eine tag so eine tat so einmal zweimal
laufen wissen wir nicht wohin damit
die pandemie bleibt allgegenwärtig
testen für den oster besuch schon bis
mittag erfuhren in diesem test zentrum
15 menschen von ihrer infektion die
reaktionen zum teil geschockt waren dann
aber zum teil auch gefasst weil sie halt
wussten weil sie kontakt hatten zu
jemandem und deswegen heute zu uns
gekommen sind in hessen kämpft die
polizei in der nacht deshalb gleich
gegen zwei gefahren karfreitag auto
freitag selbst im katholischen folge
sie trifft sich die tuning szene ein
großeinsatz von illegale rennen
verhindern und allzu enge kontakte die
gesellen sich jetzt zusammen und
gefährten sich natürlich noch mal
zusätzlich zu dem normalen poser
verhalten weitgehend corona freie zone
dagegen die strände der nordsee trotz
strandkorb wetter sind hier nur einzelne
gruppen unterwegs da kommt sehnsucht auf
nach besseren tagen
anderes bild heute in stuttgart dort
haben tausende anhänger der sogenannten
querdenken bewegung gegen die korona
maßnahmen demonstriert viele hielten
sich weder an masken pflicht noch
mindestabstand die polizei war mit
mehreren hundert einsatzkräften vor ort
trotz mehrfacher verstöße gegen die
auflagen ließen die behörden die
kundgebung laufen und das sind die
korona zahlen an diesem samstag wegen
der feiertage sind sie allerdings
weniger aussagekräftig das robert koch
institut meldet 18.000 129 neue
infektionen innerhalb eines tages das
sind 2343 weniger als vor einer woche
120 menschen starben in verbindung mit
cupid 19
die sieben tage incidents sinkt leicht
auf 131,4 der frühling lockt nach
draußen
dort ist die ansteckungsgefahr zwar
geringer aber ein restrisiko bleibt in
der zdf- heute- app erfahren sie was
beim treffen im freien wichtig ist zum
durchklicken lohnt es sich knallhart
runterzufahren
offenbar ja das liegt das beispiel
portugals nach einem harten lockdown
kann das land vorsichtig wieder öffnen
und das nachdem noch im januar die
dritte corona welle das land überrollte
wie kein zweites in der eu auf trial in
den krankenhäusern folgten strikte
ausgangssperren von fast 900 neue
infektionen pro 100.000 einwohner sank
die sieben tage incidents rapide auf
aktuell 28 christel hass
bleiben sie zu hause leuchtend rot die
aufforderung an alle autofahrer in
lissabon portugal ist immer noch im
lockdown reisen im eigenen land strikt
verboten
und fast alle halten sich daran der
strand von karavelas nördlich der
hauptstadt so gut wie menschenleer
die die hier luft schnappen wohnen auch
hier müssen alles sehr langsam angehen
damit wir nicht wieder solche zustände
haben wie an weihnachten
es hängt jetzt vom verhalten der
menschen ab ob wir die situation
dauerhaft verändern können
portugal hat im kampf gegen korona
erstaunliches geschafft im januar war es
das am schlimmsten betroffene land der
eu und ging in einen harten lockdown
jetzt gilt es als musterknabe
rushdies pippo die portugiesen haben
sich genau an die regeln gehalten masken
tragen und abstand heißen und das hat
einen großen einfluss auf die aktivität
und die verbreitung des virus das land
öffnet sich jetzt vorsichtig
grundschulen friseure und straßenverkauf
auch wenn die infektionszahlen wieder
leicht steigen will die regierung ihren
lockerungs fahrplan fortsetzen
ab montag können die terrassen wieder
öffnen aber es dürfen nur vier personen
zusammen sitzen auch im freien müssen
alle vorsichtsmaßnahmen eingehalten
werden
kritik und widerstand gegen die korona
politik gibt es kaum
zu tief sitzt noch der schock der
weihnachts welle portugal glaubt fest
daran einen weg aus der krise gefunden
zu haben
zurück nach deutschland in baden
württemberg stehen die zeichen wieder
auf grün schwarz trotz des widerstands
an der grünen basis
die partei von ministerpräsident
kretschmann einigte sich bei einem
abschließenden sondierungsgespräch mit
der cdu auf koalitionsverhandlungen
das ziel sei nun ein ambitioniertes
klimaschutzprogramm umzusetzen aus
stuttgart am berg linke am nachmittag in
stuttgarter halbhöhenlage pressetermin
der wohl künftigen koalitionspartner
das wahlergebnis habe die gewichte in
baden württemberg zugunsten der grünen
verschoben betont ministerpräsident
kretschmann wenn es erneut zu einer grün
schwarzen landesregierung kommt ist
allen beteiligten klar das wird keine
bloße fortsetzung der bisherigen
koalition es wird ein neuanfang ein
neuanfang um gas zu bewahren was uns
lieb und teuer ist für diese koalition
gilt
wir wollen in einem guten klima viel
fürs klima tun
ein paar der dazu vereinbarten punkte
photovoltaik pflicht für häuslebauer
1000 neue windräder verbesserte
nahverkehr
das half winfried kretschmann bei seiner
überzeugungsarbeit für eine neue grün
schwarze koalition bei den grünen
entfernt hatte es zunächst viele
gegenstimmen gegeben
zumal das agieren der cdu in den letzten
eineinhalb jahren in der regierung
einige von uns grünen auch sehr
frustriert hat aber wir waren uns einig
am ende geht es nicht um die
vergangenheit sondern um die zukunft
unseres landes
jetzt starten demnächst die echten
verhandlungen für eine grün schwarze
koalition im stuttgarter landtag in die
usa dort wen nach einem angriff auf das
kapitol in washington die flaggen auf
halbmast aus respekt für die polizei
sagt der us-präsident beiden ein
autofahrer war gestern abend in eine
absperrung des kongresses gefahren
dabei tötete er einen beamten einen
verletzte er schwer
der 25 jährige angreifer wurde
erschossen das gelände um das kapitol
ist immer noch weiträumig abgeriegelt
ein terroristischer hintergrund wird
derzeit ausgeschlossen
schauen wir noch nach ägypten
dort wird heute die jahrtausende alte
hochkultur des landes wieder ein
stückweit lebendig nicht weniger als 22
fahrer ohne und pharaonen sind bald auf
den straßen kairos unterwegs in einer
großen parade entlang des wegs die
linien wechseln sozusagen ihr museum
oliver dollar es ist ein mega event in
kairo die goldene parade der pharaonen
bei der 22 mumien zu ihrer neuen
ruhestätte gebracht werden wird auf
nahezu allen sendern übertragen das
ereignis lockt menschenmassen auf die
strasse obwohl in der millionenstadt
kairo das corona virus wütet doch die
mehr als 3000 jahre alten könige wurden
damals fährt als götter haben bis heute
an bedeutung nicht verloren es ist ein
internationales ereignis das es so nicht
wieder geben wird wie sehen die könige
die ausziehen neues zuhause
großartig dann haben sie es der zweite
regierte von 12 79 vor christi 66 jahre
lang seine mumie ist die wohl
bekannteste die vom alten ägyptischen
museum in das neu gebaute nationalmuseum
für ägyptische zivilisation ziehen wird
ägyptens früherer antikenchef der
weltbekannte ägyptologe sei ja was
brachte seine expertise und viele seiner
ideen dort ein schon jetzt schwärmt er
von der neuen ausstellung der mumien
designt wie entwarfen das museum um dort
immobilien in ihren gräbern zu zeigen
wie sie bestattet wurden es wird erklärt
wie die mumifizierung durchgeführt wurde
wir zeigen die reise der mumie ins
jenseits die sarkophage der könige und
all ihre gegenstände akribisch von
langer hand wurde der umzug der mumien
geplant die transportbehälter hier bei
einem test voll mit technik wichtig sind
temperaturen luft gehalt dazu darf es
keine erschütterungen geben damit die
könige keinen schaden nehmen
was für ein spektakel ja und jetzt du
mit fußball auch inspektor borussia
dortmund hat im kampf um die champions
league qualifikation einen herben
rückschlag erlitten und gegen eintracht
frankfurt den direkten konkurrenten um
die begehrten plätze der königsklasse
eine niederlage einstecken müssen hier
sind die samstags ergebnisse vom 27
spieltag dortmund eintracht frankfurt 1
zu 2 gelungenes debüt für leverkusens
neuen trainer hannes wolf 2 2 1 gegen
schalke wolfsburg weiter auf
champions-league-kurs 1 0 gegen den fc
köln
die abstiegsbedrohten clubs mainz und
bielefeld trennen sich 1 1 augsburg
hoffenheim 2 1 das topspiel leipzig
gegen bayern münchen im aktuellen
sportstudio ebenso wie gladbach gegen
freiburg keine veränderung in den oben
in der oberen tabellenhälfte bayern
münchen vor leipzig und wolfsburg
frankfurt schon mit sieben punkten
vorsprung vor dortmund leverkusen jetzt
punktgleich mit der borussia
mönchengladbach kann am abend noch
plätze gutmachen augsburg verbessert
sich von 13 auf 11 auf dem
relegationsplatz köln bielefeld
abgeschlagenes schlusslicht schalke hoch
im kurs steht die bundesliga natürlich
wie immer im aktuellen sportstudio gast
ist heute leverkusens sportdirektor rudi
völler ja und in der englischen premier
league kassierte fc chelsea mit seinem
trainer thomas tuchel eine heftige
blamage
die blauen seit der 29 minute in
unterzahl verlieren gegen west bromwich
albion mit
25 bereits nach der ersten halbzeit
führt der tabellenvorletzte mit 2 zu 1
den schlusspunkt in der umkämpften
partie setzt carl vinson in der
nachspielzeit der neunzigsten minute zum
5 2-sieg und die fußballerinnen von
eintracht frankfurt stehen zum
vierzehnten mal im dfb pokal finale der
verein der zu beginn der saison als
erster ffc frankfurt an den start
gegangen war besiegte im halbfinale sc
freiburg mit 2 zu 1 der rückstand dem
die dunkel gekleideten frankfurterinnen
hinterherlaufen müssen kommt durch marin
müller in der 14 minute zustande
die freiburgerinnen bringt das gäste
team in führung zwei minuten nach der
pause gelingt frankfurt der ausgleich
durch clara prasnikar
und es klappt dann mit dem versuch den
neunmaligen rekordpokalsieger erneut ins
finale zu bringen
die 17 jahre alte camilla klüver macht
den entscheidenden treffer zum 2 1 über
freiburg in der 63 minute damit stehen
die frauen von eintracht frankfurt
erstmals seit 2004 wieder im pokalfinale
damals noch als erster ffc frankfurt die
eintracht hat auch den laufenden richtig
gut super stimmung auch bei den frauen
das wars vom sport was jetzt nicht so
verwunderlich ist wenn sie ein erster
ausflug planen dann besser morgen denn
der ostermontag soll wettermäßig
ziemlich eklig werden die details hat
gleich katja horneffer direkt danach
sehen sie die rede des bundespräsidenten
um viertel vor elf begrüßt sie dann
christian sievers im heute journal
wir wünschen ihnen einen unbeschwerten
abend danke dass sie dabei waren und bis
morgen
denn sie mögen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren heute nacht
ist es meist klar und die temperaturen
sinken auf plus fünf bis minus fünf grad
morgen gibt es in norddeutschland
dichtere wolken sonst aber scheint
häufig die sonne besonders strahlend
hier im südwesten
so steigen die temperaturen im saarland
und zwischen dem rhein main gebiet und
dem oberrhein noch mal auf 13 bis 15
grad sonst bleibt es bei acht bis zwölf
grad deutlich kälter an ostermontag
erwarten uns dann schnee schnee regen
und graupel gewitter von nordwesten bei
einem starken bis stürmischen wind aus
nordwest und auch danach geht es sehr
wechselhaft und winterlich weiter vor
ostern